question s'est passé ça moi je n'étais
pas sûr pas droit oui moi j'aurais voulu
vous poser une question concernant le
modèle world 3 qui vient des limites de
la croissance et dont les prédictions
sont quand même un peu khalip tic je
pense qu'on peut le dire donc eux y
voyait en tout cas le modèle business a
jugé celui qu'on a l'air de suivre le
scénario qu'on a l'air de suivre
à l'ère de prédire un effondrement de
civilisation dans les années 2030 entre
2030 2040
je veux savoir ce que vous pensez de ça
parce qu'il ya eu quand même quelques
études qui ont l'air de montrer que
l'effet colle assez bien aux modèles
notamment celle de ternat dont je serais
curieux de connaître votre opinion là
dessus c'est que la ligne de pente nous
en mettent pas nécessairement vers un
long fleuve tranquille donc world 3 pour
ceux d'entre vous qui sont pas familiers
de méduses pour ceux d'entre vous qui
sont pas familiers non plus meadows
était un scientifique du hem haïti qui a
travaillé dans une équipe qui n'avait
pas fondées dû rester foresters qui
avait fondé l'équipe et qu'ils aident la
dynamique des systèmes et à vraiment cet
homme qui devait avoir des nuits un peu
trop longue s'est demandé comment les
raccourcir et donc il s'est dit je vais
essayer de faire un modèle qui
représente la dynamique du système
population humaine dans son
environnement
donc il a fait un modèle dans lequel il
a une population qui est comment dire
qui a ses propres déterminant elle
cherche à s'alimenter elle cherche à
profiter de services industriels etc
et puis elle est limitée parce que
l'environnement peut lui offrir c'est à
dire une limite de surface cultivable de
ressources extractibles etc
et puis meadows il regarde comment est
ce que le système peut évoluer compte
tenu de la manière dont il a déjà évolué
jusqu'à maintenant et il en tire une
conclusion cardinal une seule il dit
tant que l'humanité a pour objectif de
croître en volume donc plus de monde
consomme en plus la seule chose qui est
absolument certaine c'est que à un
moment ou à un autre le système
s'effondre sur lui même après avoir
bouffé tout le capital qui l'entourent
alors il ya deux manières de bouffer le
capital vous pouvez le bouffer par
l'extraction ou pour le bouffer par la
pollution la pollution perturbant enfin
dégradant la qualité des actifs restants
jusqu'à 10 mai lowe's et donc meadows
dit
tel que soit l'optimisme que je puisse
prendre sur les conditions initiales la
quantité de ressources extractibles etc
si les hommes cherchent la croissance ou
même la cherche trop longtemps il la
cherche jusqu'en 1981 président je
m'arrête et bien à ce moment le système
finit par s'effondrer sur lui même c'est
ce qu'avait dit meadows alors la façon
dont le système s'effondre c'est que à
un moment l'alimentation disponible par
personne se met à baisser les services
industriels disponibles par personne se
met à baisser puis la population jamais
abaissé et tout ça de manière subite
évidemment mélodies l'a pas dit à quel
moment tel pays fera la guerre à tel
autre pays et c'est ça que vous avez que
trois manières de faire mourir les gens
c'est la famine la maladie la guerre il
n'a pas d'autre donc une contraction
rapide de la population c'est un monde
dans lequel se généralise des famines
des maladies et guerre malheureusement
assez arithmétique donc ce qu'on est en
train de jouer avec la prévention des
grands problèmes que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est ça hein
cette affaire dont on parle on est en
train de jouer la prévention de la
famine de la maladie et de la guerre
voilà je sais pas si c'est pas des
problèmes un peu plus important que
l'intelligence artificielle à côté et si
par ailleurs ça ne justifierait pas qu
on augmente un peu le prix de l'essence
et d'un certain nombre d'autres dents et
que nous trouvons aujourd'hui à gogo
voilà mais mon arbitrage personnel en
tout cas je pense que de poser de
problèmes comme ça ça fait un peu
réfléchir et qu'elles sont pas ici dans
une conférence intitulée énergie et
climat
qu'est-ce qu'on fait président vous
disiez la quantité de gens qui
travaillent dans l'agriculture dans un
pays donné est une fonction inverse de
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne est-ce que c'était une image à
des fins pédagogiques ou une relation
mathématique confirmée par l'histoire
des faits en ce sens est ce que vous
pensez comme l'écrivait philippe
desbrosses à la fin des années 80 que
nous redeviendrons paysans pour l'avenir
de nos enfants alors je pense que si
vous attendez suffisamment longtemps un
jour effectivement ce qu'il restera de
l'espèce humaine en deviendra paysanne
oui je sais pas vous dire quand et je
sais pas vous dire par quel processus
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'aujourd'hui la
productivité agricole du début du 19e
siècle ne permet pas d'installer sur la
terre 7 milliards d'individus
donc on en revient exactement au propos
précédents faut bien voir que les
combustibles fossiles nous ont permis là
où ça a fait entre guillemets mentir
malthus parce que moi je me suis arrêté
à essai sur le principe de population
avant d'avoir vu ses calculs savants sur
à quel moment le système s'arrête donc
j'ai lu toute la partie avant très
intéressantes notamment toutes ces
tables de mortalité dans lequel il
explique à quel âge les gens meurent
dans les diverses régions du monde en
1800 et de quoi mais c'est passionnant
mais par contre ce qui est sûr c'est que
ce qui a fait mentir malthus c'est qu'on
ait découvert les combustibles fossiles
donc on a remplacé les animaux de trait
qui mangent du sol par des esclaves qui
mangent du sous sol
donc on a libéré tout l'espace pour nous
et par ailleurs on a augmenté la
productivité du sol parce que malthus
avait pas vu venir grâce aux
combustibles fossiles de le voilà mais
ça a déplacé l'échéance oui c'est une
question vous dites alors une première
étape pour que les choses évoluent et
d'informer et donc ce que vous faites
notamment
mais on voit bien par exemple avec le
rapport meadows qu'en fait il ya des
personnes qui ont été informés à un
moment donné et qui ont fait en sorte
d'enterrer ces informations puisqu'il
n'a pas été diffusée qu'en fait une fois
qu'on a informé d'ailleurs un autre
blocage et comment on peut agir sur le
blocage qui est des personnes qui sont
en mesure de diffuser largement des
informations et qui les diffusent pas je
pense que la raison je me suis longtemps
posé la question de savoir pourquoi est
ce que mes doses avait pas engendré une
école académique parce que pour ceux
d'entre vous qui l'ont lu il faut lire
l'édition originale dans son jus de
limitrophes en 72 c'est un bouquin ya
pas une virgule a changé c'est lumineux
un des bouquins les plus magistraux que
j'ai lu et donc la question c'est
pourquoi est-ce que ce type qui avait
contribué à un travail brillantissime ou
à mon avis du reste pour établir plus
que l'égalité des sexes je crois que
c'est par hasard qu'il ait mis sa femme
en premier je crois que c'était aussi
quelqu'un d' extrêmement brillant mais
alimente est bien la question c'est
pourquoi est ce que il n'a pas engendré
une école de pensée parce qu'en fait la
seule manière de faire durer
quelque chose de cette nature c'est
d'installer cette pensée dans un corps
constitué et qui résistent au temps qui
est toujours là pour dire des choses et
pour évoluer et en fait j'ai fini par
arriver à une conclusion personnelle que
je vous propose je suis pas complètement
sûr de bons coups mais c'est ce que je
crois je crois que la fère s'est perdue
dans les sables
il a été extrêmement lu le rapport du
club de rome ça a été je pourquoi dix ou
vingt millions d'exemplaires enfin je
dis un truc extrêmement lui mais la
raison pour laquelle ça n'a rien d'un
gendre et d'autres c'est que meadows
n'avait pas de clients c'est à dire
qu'il ya pas de métro du monde et donc
quand vous vous intéressez au sort du
monde dans son ensemble
vous n'avez personne en face qui vous
dit à cet intéressant creuse donc je
vais voir ce que je peux en faire n'a
pas de maître du monde est la raison
pour laquelle les économistes classiques
qui pourtant vous l'avez compris tout à
l'heure en filigrane quand ils utilisent
des modèles macroéconomiques raconte
juste du grand n'importe quoi
je vous invite par exemple aller
regarder les projections
macroéconomiques de tous les organismes
de place et de confronter sa ce qui
s'est vraiment passé
donc vous prenez les projections il ya
un an il ya deux ans il ya 3 ans et 4
ans il ya cinq ans il ya dix ans puis
vous regardez ce qui s'est vraiment
passé
c'est à pisser de rire normalement si
vous voulez faire des économies
budgétaires tous ces gens là vous
l'écoutez la porte juste à rien et bien
servent à rien et j'utilise un modèle
faut à cause de ce que j'ai raconté tout
à l'heure sauf que eux ils ont des
clients
parce que comme ils prétendent raconter
des choses justes à l'échelle d'une
maille où il ya des gens pour agir c'est
à dire des pays eux ils ont des clients
ok ils ont un business donc meadows ce
qui lui a manqué à l'époque c'est d'être
capable de désagréger son mode de pensée
à l'échelle d'un pays
et alors évidemment ça devient beaucoup
plus compliqué parce que les ressources
sur la terre vous pouvez pas les faire
venir de mars pas beaucoup alors que les
ressources dans un pays vous pouvez les
faire venir du pays d'un côté donc
rendre le modèle de meadows pertinent à
la maille d'un pays c'était prendre en
compte les flux d'import export et
c'était enfin tout un tas de trucs que
meadow je ne savais pas prendre en
compte
donc c'est pour ça à mon avis qu'il a
été bloqué dans sa ligne de pensée
aujourd'hui il a un disciple lointain
qui est un ami qui s'appelle gagner le
giro qui est en train d'essayer de
refaire meadows mais à lui avec un
modèle macroéconomique qui s'applique à
la maille d'un pays donc s'il y arrive
1 il méritera peut-être le prix nobel
enfin qu'il n'est pas le prix nobel je
vous rappelle que le prix de la banque
de suède en mémoire d'alfred nobel c'est
pas un prix nobel
les autres c'était vraiment des coquins
ces économistes et le indépendamment de
cela il aura recréer du meadows mais à
l'échelle d'un pays
alors évidemment il aura recréer du
meadows avec les mêmes conclusions sert
qu'à un moment la fête s'arrête donc là
il faudra voir s'il a des clients
j'ai vu une question oui c'est ici je
suis là non